Speaker 1: There is something really interesting
Speaker 2: going on with now Senate Minority
Speaker 1: Leader Mitch McConnell,
Speaker 2: the Republican
senator from Kentucky, one
Speaker 1: Republican senator
Speaker 2: from Kentucky.
Speaker 1: Now I want to
be really clear Mitch McConnell is still a
disgusting Republican. He maneuvered to keep
Barack Obama's Supreme Court pick
Speaker 2: out of the Supreme Court
and Russian Donald
Speaker 1: Trump's pick,
Speaker 2: specifically thinking about Amy
Speaker 1: Coney Barrett, his morals,
his political views. They're vile in
every way, and that doesn't change. But.
As a curiosity, Mitch McConnell
appears to have sort of had enough
Speaker 2: of the extreme pro-Trump wing
Speaker 1: of the party trashing him,
Speaker 2: and he might be ready to throw
Speaker 1: Trumpists into the proverbial trash.
I'm going to play a clip for you here in
which Mitch McConnell was asked during
a press conference.
Speaker 4: Did you
Speaker 2: speak to Mark Meadows on January
Speaker 1: 6th as we learn about all of the
different people that did? And what is
your thought about all of it and the
involvement of these Fox News hosts
with Meadows in the administration?
Speaker 2: And Mitch says,
Speaker 1: I didn't speak to Mark Meadows,
but I am interested
Speaker 2: to see all of the
Speaker 1: participants who
Speaker 2: were involved revealed,
Speaker 1: and I'm getting the sense
that he's ready to let them hang. So
check out the clip. Here's Mitch McConnell
Speaker 5: learning from the House Select
Committee that a number of Republicans have
reached out to mark Meadows asking for Donald
Trump to get more involved and do more on
Jan. six to secure this building. Were you
personally in contact with Mark Meadows
that day in other White House officials
to urge Trump to do more? You know, I was not.
But I do think we're all watching as you are
what is unfolding on the house side. And it will
be interesting to reveal all the participants who
were involved. Were you concerned about
Speaker 2: Mitch McConnell and other
Speaker 1: establishment Republicans
have been targeted by personal
Speaker 2: attacks and name-calling and hostility
Speaker 1: by Trump and Trumpists
for a year now? I think that Mitch is sick of
it. I think it has had a major impact on him.
Look at all of the people that Donald Trump
has endorsed so far for 2022. Many of them
have said I would not support Mitch McConnell
being the leader of Republicans in the Senate.
Speaker 2: Trump has said Mitch McConnell
Speaker 1: should leave the
position. Trump has said Mitch
Speaker 2: McConnell is bad now,
Speaker 1: you know, to use very simplistic
language. And to be fair. Mitch McConnell
is also closing in on retirement. There is no
defense of Mitch McConnell or of establishment
Speaker 2: Republicans, but this is a
Speaker 1: recognition
that Mitch really may have no
Speaker 2: interest at all
Speaker 1: in running interference for
the people that might be brought down by
the January 6th Committee, and that includes
other Republicans from the more sycophantic
pro-Trump wing of the Republican Party. Now, if
we zoom out, I don't expect this to change the
Republican Party in any substantive way.
Speaker 2: But I do hope that it will be
Speaker 1: another element of this
building Republican Civil War,
Speaker 2: pro-Trump versus anti-Trump,
Speaker 1: which, if we're lucky,
will interfere with Republicans being able to run
solid campaigns. And hopefully, I mean, if the
left can get it together, will allow for some
Speaker 2: victories by Democrats and others
Speaker 1: on the left. That's my interest
in this. I'm being very upfront with you that
that's my horse in the race, so to speak. And at
the end, there is no real moral stance here for
Mitch McConnell. It's just what's in
Speaker 2: it for him. It's bad
Speaker 1: for him. If there are more Republicans
in the House and Senate that don't like him,
it's bad for him.
Speaker 2: If Republicans
who won't support his leadership
Speaker 1: get elected to the Senate,
he doesn't like being called names. He might
want revenge. That's all it is. There's no big
moral awakening here for Mitch McConnell. It's
just if it's bad for him, he'll be against it.
Speaker 2: And it seems pretty clear at
Speaker 1: this point
Speaker 2: that the Trumpist wing of the
Speaker 1: Republican Party
isn't particularly big on Mitch McConnell, so it's
Speaker 2: going to be fascinating
Speaker 1: to watch. I continue to believe that
the Left should inflame this Republican civil war
as much as the left can. It can only be good
for the left. It might not do that much good,
Speaker 2: but it's not going
Speaker 1: to be bad and it might be good.
Speaker 2: And so it's worth doing.
Speaker 1: All right. Two announcements
today. Number one, yesterday's town hall
had to be rescheduled, a combination of tech
Speaker 2: issues and YouTube
Speaker 1: Live being in and out
right when the town hall was scheduled means we
have rescheduled it for two weeks from yesterday.
The new town hall date is December 28th, 6:00 PM
Eastern. That will really be the last one of the
year because it's like three days from the end
of the year. So December 28th, 6:00 PM Eastern,
that's the new date. Secondly, we are planning
Speaker 2: on the
Speaker 1: biggest ever one day membership bomb
on January 1st, 2022. We will notify everybody
on our mailing list of an ungodly membership
discount on January 1st. Get on my mailing
Speaker 2: list at David Pakman
Speaker 1: dot com to be notified on that very,
very special day, which will sort of be
Speaker 2: the unofficial kickoff of
the midterm election. So just sign
Speaker 1: up for the mailing list
at David Pakman dot com. We'll take a quick break
and it is. Quite a program we have for you today.